we are all writers now whether you want
to write a book or a blog or better text
messages or emails I want to help you
with a free ebook called 11 ways to
write better you can find that at the
minimalists com slash resources enjoy
it's creativity learner balandin
provable if so how how do you make it
natural instead of something forced of
course it has to be learn abour right
because because when you're born I'm I'm
thinking of Ella when she was
one-year-old like she wasn't very
creative created poop that was about it
though right and so yeah we of course we
learned how to be creative in fact as
kids kids are most creative why because
they're unfiltered and so that's really
the answer to Tom's questions here how
do you make it natural you remove those
filters what are the filters filters are
all someone's gonna judge me someone's
gonna think poorly of this someone's not
going to like this these are the filters
that we create I I don't want to
embarrass myself if you can remove those
filters that's we're creative creativity
comes from now why are kids so creative
because they're constantly asking
questions they have a willingness and
ability to ask questions regardless of
how mundane or silly or stupid they
might seem they don't care they're gonna
ask the Ella's favorite word for many
years was why why why and now of course
in the schooling system we almost beat
that out of them and and and by the time
we're 18 years old we are afraid to ask
why because it's so uncool well get
really uncool if you want to be creative
right and by the way here's the paradox
of that Ryan the people who are the real
creators who are able to step past the
uncool phase there are the coolest
people they are because they create
something that is meaningful and there's
nothing cooler than that yeah the only
thing a lot here tom is personally I
love to draw like little and it's not
all the time but sometimes I get this
wild here I get this like pattern in my
head and they're always like really
simple patterns and I'm like oh I wonder
what this would look like on paper so I
literally have like like a charcoal
pencil in a book that I will go to and I
would never show anyone any of these
drawings yeah but it's just fun to like
work out sometime
but as I you know do it they get a
little bit better and better and you
know it's not again nothing like I would
ever plan on putting public this time
but yes I mean it is improvable and the
only way you improve on it is by doing
it so it doesn't happen via osmosis
right
you